I have a video for you today of MSNBC
host Chris Matthews getting his black
guys confused and the video is so
cringeworthy that I'm going to recommend
you get the kids out of the room Chris
Matthews is now again being asked to
resign he last week equated Bernie
Sanders win in Nevada to a Nazi invasion
of France
he now has embarrassingly mixed up
prominent black politicians on live
television check this out in South
Carolina there are two Republican
senators there Lindsey Graham who is
white and Tim Scott who is black there
is a second black candidate named Jamie
Harrison we've been talking about him
he's challenging Lindsey Graham he's an
establishment centrist type Democrat
very involved with the South Carolina
Democratic Party but he would be way
better than Lindsey Graham and Chris
Matthews was set up to interview Jamie
Harrison MSNBC put up a video on the
screen of Lindsey Graham standing next
to Tim Scott and Chris Matthews thought
that it was Jamie Harrison standing next
to Lindsey Graham it gets very awkward
you'll hear other people on the set in
the background very quickly and
repeatedly saying Tim Scott Tim Scott
Tim Scott trying to avert disaster for
Chris Matthews it's really bad let's
take a look Jamie I see you standing
next to the guy you're gonna beat right
there maybe maybe maybe Lindsey Graham
Scott Sims guy Jamie who's that Tim
Scott Hey
oh it's the other side what am I saying
big mistake mistaken identity sir sorry
tell me how you gonna be done the crazy
thing is that the video of Tim Scott and
Lindsey Graham is live video from a
rally happening right then and there I
don't know how Chris Mathews thought
that the person he was about to
interview Jamie Harrison was live at a
rally with Lindsey Graham at the same
time like every aspect of it is weird
and confusing and it has been a very bad
week for Chris Mathews first he said
that Jewish candidate Bernie Sanders
winning Nevada
was like Nazis invading France then he
put out this mealy-mouthed apology that
felt relatively insincere then he gets
two black politicians confused live on
air and then on top of all of this most
recently he's now been accused of sexual
harassment by GQ columnist no a
columnist Laura Bassett who says that
when they were getting make up a next to
each other back in 2016 Chris Matthews
looked over and said why haven't I
fallen in love with you yet she laughed
nervously and said nothing and then
Chris Matthews said to the makeup artist
keep putting makeup on her I'll fall in
love with her Bassett also says that
another time Matthew stood between her
and a mirror and complimented her red
dress asking are you going out tonight
when she said she didn't know he said to
the makeup artist make sure you wipe
this off her face after the show we
don't make her up so some guy in a bar
can look at her like this
it's not going well for Chris Matthews
once again a new round of calls
resignation with in seven days two
different situations that are leading to
people calling for his resignation my
question to you does Chris Matthews
survive this at MSNBC and quite frankly
does anybody care IIIi would I would ask
you for the answers to both of those
questions let me know I want to give a
quick shout out to one of our sponsors
VIN Chara watches they're giving my
audience 15% off your entire order when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch
maybe you don't usually wear a watch and
you've been thinking about looking for
one to elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have check out vin chair oh it's an
American company all of their watches
are built in small batches from high-end
materials they look amazing and they
look like something you'd spend a lot of
money on but ever even Cheryl watch
ranges from a hundred and fifty to three
hundred dollars I went on their website
and picked out the kairos in white and
silver really love the look the
combination of the white face and the
beige band really loved this one they
also sent me
Kairos limited release gold reserve set
totally different style this one would
make a fantastic gift for a couple
people I can think of in my family any
time you see me wearing a watch on the
show I'm wearing a Venera watch go
through their collection I know you'll
find something you like and you'll get
15% off when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch